so let's talk about capitalism
let's talk about capitalism we have
different economical systems in the
world
you know no matter how much i study what
you say
you'll take shots at obama then you'll
take shots at bush
and you'll take shots at nixon then
you'll take shots at rock carter
then you'll take shots at trump so it's
not like you are
blindly no matter what only defending
anybody that
is on one side you're not that that's
not you you're not a
uh a such and such person such a perfect
leader he can never make a mistake
you don't come from that gives you a lot
of credibility as a reader to say i'm
actually interested to see what he's
thinking about it
here but if we look at economical
systems we've got capitalism we've got
socialism we got communism
and then you know a couple other things
marxism would be pretty much the same as
socialism communism
a part of it what what do you think
about like when you when you think about
capitalism out of all the systems that
we've had
and the results that capitalism has
created what are your thoughts on
capitalism
well first of all i have a different
conception of the
various options in the world you see
many different kinds i see
one every society
that's functioning has some variety of
state capitalism
uh some elements of capitalism
constrained by state power that's true
the united states
it's true of britain it was true of
russia under the
so-called communists that's true of
china
uh we can look at the different variants
of state capitalism that exist
i think they all have some advantages
many defects now as far as
just my discussing biden
obama bush and so on
there are two kinds of we have a certain
we have a finite amount of time and
energy
we can decide how to use it one way to
use it
is to march in parades praising
the magnificence of our leaders and uh
countries along with great mass of other
people
pretty useless activity in my opinion
the other
the other possibility is to see what's
wrong
with existing societies and work to try
to change them my feeling is
that's where attention and energy
should be devoted so every one of those
figures that you mentioned
did a lot of things that i think were
very wrong very harmful
to others and ourselves and i think
not just them but the people around them
the social forces that
within which they were functioning and
so on so i think the sensible
thing to do is look at those and try to
improve and change them
if that is an impression of being
negative
yes it's true i think we should be
negative about things that ought to be
changed
if you want to applaud join the
multitudes and the parades and
praise what's nice fine that's okay it's
not a
very worthwhile you want to do it on
july 4th okay
but not devoting your life to it so
so we should emphasize on the wrong work
that you do
you're saying so as an as a reader
you've written 150 books so rather than
looking at ideas you have in your book
that makes sense i as the reader should
look at the things that's
wrong about you not the things you write
that's right about you so that's kind of
what you're suggesting
if you're if you have some special
interest in me
say you're my mother uh then
you should be interested in the things
that i do that i shouldn't be doing
okay if you care about me
if not but if not i gotta constantly be
looking so if you care about the u.s
if you care about u.s society if you
don't care about u.s society
just go marching a parade if you do care
about u.s society
you'll take a look at what you think
ought to be changed and improved
so so what you're saying is if i'm
constantly looking at things that are
wrong instead of things that are right
i should you that that to me means less
celebration
more being critical so i should spend
more time
protesting than attending parades not
just
protesting trying to change
if you care about the society at all
you'll be concerned with trying to
change
the things that are wrong that hamper
its development
that hurt the people in it and that are
harming other people in the world
you'll be committed to changing those if
you care about the society
if you don't care about the society at
all you can march in periods
yeah but you know the the i mean i get
that okay fine let's let's continue with
that so capitalism what
what is in your opinion what is wrong
with capitalism where do you see the
flaws and challenges and capitalism and
what will be a better
alternative than capitalism well first
of all since there is no
capitalism almost everything we have is
an alternative to it
everything in faith if there were
capitalism
it would probably self-destruct within
no time
that's why the business world pretty
much in charge
has always invariably called upon state
power to protect them from the
ravages of the market and to subsidize
them and to carry them through
the next stage to develop the next stage
of the economy
and so on why let's be quite concrete
we're now using computers the internet
satellites uh microelectronics
so on where'd all that come from
mostly from public investment uh
you got a vacancy from public investment
you mean the gut so
so most of the innovation we've had in
america came from the government not
from the people
that's what you're saying of course i
mean i was at mit in the 50s and 60s
when
most of this was being developed it was
being developed on public funds
so so that's a that's that's that could
be an opinion that could not be
necessarily
a fact that's another thing that could
be an opinion because you and i are on a
computer right now invented by this guy
named steve wozniak
you know take a look at computers
they were developed for the risky
creative
hard work was done for decades
either in research universities
they almost used the entire city's
electricity
they had to have massive towers to have
a computer because
in order to allow entrepreneurs lots of
electricity
which is coming from public funding
overwhelmingly
so yes if you look back at it at all
most of it just
the creative hard general work is just
done through public engagement
now you take a look at computers again
in 1977
after about 30 years of development of
computers mostly in the public
sector uh steve jobs was able
able to make a personal computer that
you could sell on the market
apple computer what i'm using uh and
then
the marketing the development and so on
was mostly
transferred to the private sector now
it's more complex than this so ibm for
example
after learning how to switch from
punch cards to uh
modern computers they learned that
mostly in labs like the one i was
working in at mit
but they did advance to that point then
they were
able to develop their own computer in
the early 60s
stretch computer fastest motto around
but nobody could buy it was way too
expensive so it went to the
public sector it was bought by los
alamos
and then it was able to develop further
and so it continued same with the
internet
which was being developed right where it
was in fact in the late 50s early 60s
public funding after about 30 years
1995 or so it was
essentially handed over to private power
uh private largely privatized
that's the way a lot of the economy
develops goes
way back to the early 19th century 19th
century
the main development in the country was
railroads
that was the huge economic development
they were much too complicated
and extensive for private capital to
deal with them
so it was handed over to the army corps
of engineers
uh the mass production
it's called the american way of
manufacturing which astonished the world
late 19th century uh quality controlled
uh replaceable parts uh
taylorism and industry all of this which
made things much more efficient
it was mostly developed in government
armors
and handed over picked up and used by
private capital
now i'm drawing the lines too sharply
you look at the
whole thing complicated story there's
all kinds of interaction
but this is a large part of economic
history
all the way through that's why we always
have state
capitalism yeah along with protection
of the masters from market ravages
they don't want to face them uh the
reason we have
huge financial institutions is because
the government
insures them and allows us i don't
disagree with that that's the part where
crony capitalism i'm not with that 1d8
the big banks got bailed out and they
got the checks in away by barack obama
or bush or
folks back in the day when reagan bailed
out i'm not the one that's sitting here
saying let's bail some of these
companies out because
in my opinion uh professor i don't think
monopoly exists without the help of the
government
i don't think i'm an appointment quite
the opposite as soon as you start
deregulating
it moves towards monopolization with
we've
seen it we've seen it that's the result
that's the result
of handing things over to the market
that's the result of politicians being
for sale
because their campaigns they need money
to raise campaigns so i can go buy them
because they're for sale
and they helped me create a monopoly
because i got a couple people in my
pocket that's that's been going on for a
while
there's a reason why a lot of these
bigger companies start off in different
cities as headquarters as they get
bigger
they put an office right in dc because i
got to go control some of the regulation
and laws to
not allow the other smaller guy to
compete with me long term
you're looking at footnotes the main
thing is that when you begin
to deregulate and hand things over to
the market
there's a tendency strong tendency to
move towards monopolization
as the bigger fish eat the littler fish
have more power
that can underprice i i we're not
we're not off page here because i've
been on calls before where the ftc
we were doing business with this one
company all of a sudden i get a call
from ftc they don't have a call with us
great so we want your entire team to be
on the call okay
what's this call about to go back to
capitalism
that's why the owners and managers of
the world
those who adam smith called the masters
of the universe
the owners of concentrated capital
that's why they have
always called on the state to rescue
them from disaster
so going back to the original point all
over the world
we have one or another variety of state
capitalism
but why do why do politicians fall for
that though why do politicians fall for
that politicians can say we're not
bailing you out why do they bail them
out
the politician doesn't have to say yes
we'll bail you out
no we're going to let the market decide
how you do why would they bail them out
sorry why would they want so you're
saying these these
masters of the universe that adam smith
talks about
they almost always go to the public to
bail him out but the public has the
right to say
no we're not going to bail you out why
do they keep saying yes because they
have very few choices no if you're
if you're if you're an individual right
and you say
i don't like the monopoly of uh
the the comcast and
right two or three what are you going
gonna do about it well no i'm gonna
the the public is to sit here but to sit
here and say everything is the private's
fault and everything good that ever
happened was because of the public and
the government not the private
that's extremely naive to say that
because you're you're then painting the
picture of the public and all the
responsibility that they have to reject
these ideas by these
truths everybody's for sale all the
politicians are foreseeable
it's the opposite i'm the one who's
saying
the public can do a lot that's what i've
been saying all along i'm writing about
you ask me who i respect it's the people
on the ground who are doing
things because they have the options so
if you like this sort of short clip from
an interview i did click over here to
watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye